where have all the men gone that's the
focus of tonight's angle
now once relegated to women's studies
classrooms and college campuses the
phrase toxic masculinity entered our
cultural vernacular a few years ago now
this was around the time that the
american psychological association
jumped in to warn that males who
socialized to conform to traditional
masculinity ideology are often
negatively affected in terms of mental
and physical health well the argument is
that boys are conditioned to be tough
and not show weakness
that's a bad thing i guess and then by
suppressing boys feelings their emotions
then they're likely to be more prone to
violence or aggression more likely to
end up in prison or in trouble at school
and people who work in gender studies
programs
they're dead set against the old
confining rules of
masculinity and you'll see this in a
highly produced hollywood
conversation
i think there's a model
about being a real man in america
and i think sometimes that model is at
more sort of stoic hard tough etc my
friend joe irman who used to be a
professional football player says that
he remembers his father
just saying to him be a man
man up
toughen up
don't be a girl
this is how far we've fallen in america
telling a boy not to be a girl
i guess is now considered abusive
we're in an upside down world my friends
and i think more people now see right
through the attempt that they're making
to kind of
wrap their attacks on traditional gender
roles
around an anti-bullying campaign
well that's absurd because real men do
not bully we know that real men don't
beat their wives we know that real men
don't hurt animals or children we know
that
all decent people agree on that
and by the way long before the phrase
gender fluid popped up
good parents told their sons both to be
a man
and to be courageous valiant
compassionate
now i heard my friend's father say stop
whining and be a man and he was
complaining about something he said it a
lot actually
it didn't hurt my buddy one bit he's a
great dad today
but today the radical left has one goal
in mind
it's to destroy the underpinnings of the
nuclear family by targeting the distinct
parental roles that fathers and mothers
play ideally
come on we all know this it's better for
children to be raised by a mother and a
father who are present
and involved
now we also all know that single moms
and dads do their best but it's much
harder god bless them all
and i say this as a single mom myself
yet somehow this idea of the traditional
roles
it's threatening to the radicals who see
the traditional family especially
traditionally minded men
as an impediment
to the ultimate goal of the left of
socialism and rewriting of american
history
now remember black lives matter had the
disruption of the nuclear family as one
of its main goals
now the entertainment industry joined
the anti-family
anti-masculinity crusade long ago
intelligent television and films male
protagonists are often portrayed as kind
of goofy helpless
uh you know helpless saps or gender
fluid geniuses
[Applause]
[Music]
it's only been since thanksgiving but it
feels like forever
news flash for hollywood
women want men to be men
obviously they also want men to be
honest and kind and sacrificial and
humble as well
but as an old friend used to say most
women i know even women who work outside
the home
prefer a man who will protect provide
and defend
and we don't want men who will elbow us
out of the way to primp in the mirror or
men whose idea of a fun afternoon is
getting a mani-pedi and a facial no
remember the man by the way the obama
people
used in ads to push obamacare
well even morning joe all those years
ago couldn't stop laughing at him this
guy which is funny
of course all the pajama boy fans are
totally shocked that young men are
flocking to non-effeminate men like
jordan peterson who wrote 12 rules for
life and they're especially furious that
millions are tuning in to listen to
manly men like joe rogan
toxic masculinity which is
that's a hilarious expression because
you need to thank toxic masculinity for
all the bridges all the all the jets all
the rockets all this toxic masculinity
if you break down all the things that
men have invented and all these toxic
men have prevented
like you from being murdered in war and
protected the country and all the
different things that you could
attribute to toxic masculinity
most of it's positive
that's why people listen to them now the
fact is the natural instinct of most men
is to protect women
but that's slowly being beaten out of
them by angry feminists or overly
feminine men who love submissive types
this seems especially to be the case in
more liberal urban areas
and the consequences are horrifying now
something that happened in a manhattan
subway car when a woman told a perturbed
african-american man to take a chill
pill watch
[Music]
[Applause]
well that went on and on but notice what
didn't happen
not a single man on that train
intervened
a more shocking incident took place in
philly last week when a woman was raped
on the l train with other passengers
aboard not a single one
did anything to help her
and earlier this week in san francisco
it was a young woman who chased down a
man who pushed an elderly asian lady to
the ground when the woman confronted the
assailant
she was stabbed three times
where were the men
frankly the mass feminization of men
should trouble women the most
the victims and all those heinous
attacks were women
who are overpowered by bad men
and because the cultural elites and
institutions have spent years
villainizing masculinity there were no
good men willing to step in to save them
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else